I'm sleeping a lot 10 hours a day, not good sleep, could my high HCB 10.1 and MCH 33.1 be a possible cause.
Of tiredness I think is 30 minutes every day of sauna too much. No admission, I have no admission
sore muscles and always tired. What are the possible causes? So is the possible cause 30 minutes of
sauna every day? I don't think so. Is the possible cause elevated MCV or MCH? So that's kind of
go through these. MCH is an MCV are are two of the measurements that you're when you're looking for
anemia. So elevated MCV and elevated MCH can be a sign of anemia. So if those are elevated but
your red blood cell count isn't suppressed, your hemoglobin isn't suppressed, and your
hematocriticin suppressed, one would say you have early anemia. If your hemoglobin's low,
your iron's low, your ferritin's low, and your hematocritic low, and then you're you have elevated
MCV, elevated MCH, elevated MCHC, then you definitely have anemia. Now the balance of all those
is trying to discern which type of anemia that I have a blog post on this on anemia. So do search
that. So you have to kind of go through these is this high but this is low. So MCH is mean
corpuscular hemoglobin. MCV is mean corpuscular volume. So it's they're used to determine
what type of anemia. So what is anemia? Anemia is low red blood cells and but it can because
from a lot of things. So you could have iron deficiency anemia. You could have B12 deficiency anemia.
You could have vitamin B6 deficiency anemia. You could have folic acid folate deficiency anemia.
So there's different types of anemia that you have to try to discern what it is. So
if a person has has high MCH, high MCV, the possibility is iron deficiency anemia, B12 anemia,
and folate anemia, possibly B6 anemia. And then you could do some other tests to try to
discern what is going on. If the person does not have elevated hobosistine, then it's you could
probably scratch the folate anemia. Then it could be just B12 or B6 anemia. If they have normal
iron levels, normal red blood cell counts, then you'd think of B12 or B6 anemia.
Could that be causing tiredness? Well, if the if you're trending worse and worse on these that I
would say yes. So lots of times I just tend to discuss with somebody on the phone today too with
early anemias, you won't get really tiredness. So if you don't have low hemoglobin,
typically you're not going to really get chronic fatigue, really exhaustive tiredness,
and you're sleeping 10 hours a day, and you're just you're still tired, you feel like it's taken
up and tell your hemoglobin is really below 10 on average. If your hemoglobin is still 12, 13,
you probably I would not say your tiredness is due to that. Remember, your tiredness can be due to
other things too. So chronic tiredness, soreness, low muscles can be due to low in a male, low test
osterone, low adrenals can be due to low thyroid. So in a female, you'd think of of low estrogen,
low progesterone, low thyroid, low adrenals. So then you also look at do I have extra stress
in my life? Can it be my adrenals are shot? This is where adaptogens really can be helpful. So adaptogens
can help boost adrenals, can help boost thyroid. So if I take adaptogens and let's say I'm
taken three to six adaptogens a day, and that really helps my energy, then it was probably adrenals
and or thyroid. If I've been taking adaptogens every day and I'm taking enough to make a difference,
but that's not touching my tiredness at all, then I want to do, you know,
blood work again and make sure I don't have more, you know, more rapid onset anemia. So
because adaptogens are going to help with anemia, adaptions are going to help with hormonal issues.
If a person, if a male has prostate cancer and they're doing things to reduce their testosterone,
or they're on testosterone reducing medications like energy and deprivation therapies,
it's not uncommon for them to have symptoms of anemia, but not have anemia because low testosterone
can give you these things, no inhibitions, sore muscles, feeling fatigued. So you have to kind of
break this down depending on, you know, blood work, depending on activity level,
depending on stress levels, and figure this out. So causes of tiredness, causes of low admission,
causes of sore muscles, I think I covered most of those things. Could it be other things? Could it
be, you know, inflammation in the body due to eating foods that you have sensitivities too? So
let's have eating gluten. I have a gluten sensitivity. Can gluten, can that cause an inflammatory
reaction? It could cause these symptoms absolutely because if you're causing inflammation of the gut,
you're going to cause inflammation of the brain. That's rule number one, inflammation of the gut equals
inflammation of the brain. You got brain inflammation. It can affect you systemically. So it can cause all
these symptoms, no inhibitions, sore muscles, just exhausted. Can't get enough sleep, tired all the
time, not sleeping well. All these things tie together. So you do a little bit more investigation to
figure out why.